all right let's start
uh thank you so much for uh joining us
for this exciting event
my name is florian carl i'm the manager
of the yale quantum institute
and i'm delighted to see so many of you
um attend this non-technical talk
presentation so we usually would have
you um over
on the yale campus for this talk but for
the time being all we can offer you
for you is the uh this seminar remotely
but we are delighted
to have um aide to glenstone um
to give us this talk on quantum science
and what led humanity
to be on the verge of harvesting quantum
computer power
so a douglas stern is the yqi deputy
director and also the kill
the carl a morse professor of applied
physics and professor physics
he's the author of einstein and the
quantum the press of the valiant surgeon
and you'll see that some of the content
from the book will be on the
presentation tonight professor stone
presented this talk in aspen at
in front of industry and government
agency leaders
in the in the last winter at the quantum
summit and we are very pleased to have
the stark
broadcast for all of you tonight and for
the public for all 145 of you
right now who have joined the seminar um
the
the mandate of the yelp quantum
institute is really to bring
quantum science and all our research and
work to you and
to the public and explain to you what
we're doing and how
the this research done by so many
students postdocs
and researchers in our labs will benefit
the regional public
in the round before we start this talk
i would like to give you a few technical
comments you will be able to
split the screen between the slides and
the video and you can
adjust the size of the speaker so you
can see our
doddlestone attack in a second and you
can also
type all your questions in the q a
feature at the bottom of the screen
we will take your question either during
the talk if they're pertinent
right now or will do a q a session
afterwards so feel free to type all your
questions in the back
the talk will be recorded and are hosted
on the yellow parliamentary website
for replay and without further further
ado
i would like you to really welcome
douglas
stone and have a delightful evening
hello guests in cyberspace um
i'm so pleased you could come and hear
this talk
which as florian said is supposed to be
non-technical
so for the technical people who've been
nice enough to uh tune in and see me
do the best i can just forgive me for
oversimplifying things
uh and i i'm very pleased that i can do
this as a webinar
or i get to speak in a room
unfortunately it's a room with
one very socially distanced person here
florian and
it's much nicer than hunching over my
screen for the zoom conference
but i don't get to see your smiling
faces
i don't get to hear your laughter which
i hope will be copious
uh and i um uh
i also don't get to see your border
confused looks
so i'm just going to think positively
about what's going on out there
and uh and go forward
so i wrote a whole book about einstein
and quantum mechanics
and in the preface of that book i said
i chose deliberately to be quite brief
on questions such as
fundamental interdeterminism in nature
and entanglement
which are very much actually the topic
of today's
talk and the question is why
and the answer is pretty simple quantum
mechanics is not rocket science
this stuff is really hard it's really
hard
it's really really really hard so
it's not something that i wanted to
impose on the
uh unsuspecting public uh
unless it was really necessary
so i try to i try to avoid uh many of
the most challenging topics which now
unfortunately or fortunately are central
to this talk
uh so um this is
this is based off of who some of you may
feel but hopefully we'll avoid this
so why now well the reason now that i'm
venturing into this difficult territory
is that i show here a map
where the red dots illustrate new
funding for quantum science adding up to
about 15 billion dollars
and i should say that there's been lots
of quantum science since
1925 uh going on
but this is a new type of quantum
science which we call quantum
information science
and 15 billion dollars of new funding to
put in perspective
the full budget of nsf in a year is 7
billion
so it's quite a bit and you see that the
big red dot there is china
and uh china has made it clear that
they're hoping to dominate
the modern communications and
information processing uh technology
sector
and so um you know certainly they're
putting a lot of effort into this
as is the united states and other places
here's a list of corporate involvement
in the united states of america with
quantum with quantum science
you see these four web tech giants
amazon
google microsoft ibm as well as other
well-known names
and a number of startups i want to make
a shout out to quantum circuits inc
which is the local startup in new haven
which
was founded by rob shulkoff and others
and also abroad there are there's
a bunch of famous uh tech names that you
can see here
including alibaba which is almost a
trillion dollar
web company in china um
and last uh about a year and a half ago
jack heidery
who was head of ai in quantum
information science at google x
came here gave a talk and when asked
said that quantum information science
will be at least as important
as ai in the tech industry
artificial intelligence that is and
here's a list of
uh of quantum new quantum centers all
founded in the last five to ten years uh
many of our
peers uh appear on this list including
the yale quantum institute
of course and there are major
international
centers which i haven't listed all of
and most recently
doe has set up a few quantum hubs
around the nation and yale is the
co-lead
of one in this part of the the country
uh with all these other partner
institutions listed below
for really focusing on the kinds of
technology we do here at yale
um and this has oh
i don't yeah it's 120 million dollars in
funding over five years and
possibly renewable um
now i want to start by saying there was
no field of quantum information science
when i got my phd
and to illustrate how long ago that was
this is a picture of me
on the mit physics department soccer
team that skinny guy with lots of hair
so you can see that that was a while ago
the things that were being studied then
were the higgs boson
gravitational waves dark matter
and string theory so all these
cutting-edge things you've heard about
even more recently in physics were
actually already targets
for big chunks of the physics community
and astrophysics etc then but not com
information science
quantum information science didn't exist
but the precursors
were people who worried about the
philosophical foundations of quantum
mechanics
that worried about the measurement
problem in quantum mechanics
and a little bit about irreversibility
in the direction of time
very much fringe activities that weren't
really
weren't considered uh real physics
okay well now of course this is
accepted as maybe the most exciting uh
frontier area in physical science and
with a connection to computer science
and mathematics
and uh it just came out of left field in
a way that i'm going to describe
so you can call that a quantum
scientific revolution or transformative
but i think it's the most surprising and
exciting
development in physics in the last 50
years in my
humble opinion so i felt we should try
to engage
the public about this quantum
information science because it is so
novel
and it could be quite important as well
so the outline of my talk is i'm going
to begin with a historical context of
course
this is sort of my thing quantum
mechanics was invented as the theory of
the microscopic world
atoms molecules nuclei the origin of
light and heat
and it was developed between about 1900
and 1930
um and there were conceptual challenges
with the new quantum theory related to
the idea of superposition and
entanglement
of the effective measurement and a
changing paradigm
for what existed in nature but
in the maturing period between 1930 and
1980
there was great success uh but
constraints
uh on what we could actually predict
from quantum theory that i'm going to
talk about
um and uh it was only the 1980s that
this radical fringe movement formed
that began to study quantum information
science
and then in the 1990s there was a eureka
moment
which created this worldwide race to
perfect the technology and specifically
to build a quantum computer which i'm
going to talk about
um and then since 2000 there's been an
effort to actually make
this uh a reality the early work was all
theoretical work
mainly theoretical work and actually the
quantum computer is a new kind of
machine
unlike any of the others we built even
using quantum mechanics to build them
and i'm going to explain why it's such a
new kind of machine
and then finally i'll briefly talk about
the social and economic impact
of quantum information science and
technology
so in 1900 the exploration of inner
space
began through the 19th century
physicists and chemists had hypothesized
that
there were smallest constituents of
matter atoms and molecules
and were able to explain the property of
gases and
some of the properties of heat and the
flow of heat using this point of view
and during that period the working
assumption was that
there would the same loss of physics of
newtonian physics
and the electromagnetism of maxwell and
faraday
would apply also to these atoms possibly
with new forces that we would discover
and that turned out not at all to be the
case
um so and this word quantum arose and
that's the first question when yes why
is it called quantum
mechanics um and it was introduced
by max planck in 1900
and he was trying to explain the
vibrations of molecules
which both act as a as a microscopic
source of heat
and also as a source of thermal
radiation and he was trying to explain
the observations of this thermal
radiation
and he was able uh he was able to
explain that only by assuming that the
vibrational energy
was quantized in the smallest unit
epsilon
we physicists are contractually required
to use
greek letters here to make it sound more
you know fancy uh so epsilon is the
smallest unit of energy
nu is the frequency of the vibration and
h is this new constant that planck
discovered called punk's constant
and because of this quantization this
vibrating molecule was assumed to only
be able to take
certain energies equal to an integer
number times
h nu and this is uh
may not immediately strike you as being
totally crazy but it is totally crazy in
a certain sense
so the macroscopic analog of this simple
oscillator would be a pendulum right and
when the pendulum
is just facing down let's say it has its
minimum energy just
potential energy no gra no kinetic
energy
and then when i displace it and let it
move it gets kinetic energy along with
the potential energy
and um the more i displace it the more
kinetic energy it's going to get
so it looks like the energy that i can
give to this
oscillator is is related to the
continuity of space and must be
continuous because it seems like i could
displace by any amount
but the implication of playing
hypothesis was that that's not the case
that actually only certain magnitudes or
amplitudes of vibration
were allowed something totally outside
of newtonian physics
now uh the young einstein showed up and
he
uh contributes to this plank had not
embraced
his hypothesis as a new law of physics
that would change mechanics but einstein
very much did
and in 1907 he wrote the following words
for although one has thought before that
the motion of molecules obeys the same
laws
that hold for the motion of bodies in
our world of sense perception
we must now assume that the energy of
elementary structures
can only assume the values zero h nu two
h nu et cetera
okay now related to this he had
introduced
uh so this was a as i say a radical
violation of newtonian mechanics
and it hints at a coming revolution
which einstein was embracing
and in fact in 1905 earlier he had
proposed
thinking about plank's work that uh
actually
the light itself could have a
particulate behavior
and that could be thought of as
consisting of little particles each with
energy
h nu which we now call the photon
uh so and that's sort of
you know that that introduced this
strange idea that light
could at once be a wave and a particle
because light interferes with itself and
it also
um uh you know we have a we had a theory
of light waves not of light particles
so einstein eventually embraced the idea
that there was going to be a new theory
with wave particle duality
which is indeed what happens now one of
the interesting things is that
quantization appears somewhat naturally
for waves when they're confined
okay so for example if i tie a string at
two points
and i uh vibrate it then
all of its vibrations can be reduced to
certain quantized vibrations with a
fundamental
half wavelength and then the next
overtone with a full wavelength and then
three halves and so on
and this is the harmonic series that a
lot of people know
in music um and there's a natural
quantization you cannot have
frequencies in between these allowed
harmonics
so if there was wave particle duality
maybe that could lead
to quantization now actually einstein
focuses his research
mainly on quantum theory not on
relativity between 1907 and 1911
and by the end of 1910 he gave up
and uh he wrote the riddle of radiation
will not yield
so uh but just at that time
actually all the other people who had
not quite
recognized the looming crisis uh in
physics
they realized there was a crisis there
was this famous first
solve a conference in november 1911
on the topic of radiation and quanta um
and there you see mr salve
this wealthy industrialist who paid for
this
um not unlike events now at the aspen
institute etc and uh there's there's
einstein
uh but actually he was very disappointed
because he'd already
run into a brick wall and he wrote to
his friend michaela besso
that the conference was like the
lamentations on the ruins of jerusalem
i did not find it very stimulating
because i did not hear anything that i
did not already
know so so uh the next person then to
to really make progress was niels bohr
who actually found out about this solve
a conference
from rutherford um and uh he introduced
this model of an atom
where again you had quantization but
this was quantization in terms of
different orbits now it was known by
that time
that the newt that the atom consisted of
a nucleus which was positively charged
and negative electrons and you could
think of them orbiting in a kind of
solar system
model but of course in in classical
physics the orbits could have any radius
but poor proposed with some
justification
some argument not completely rigorous
that only certain
um orbits would be allowed and the only
thing that could happen is that an
electron could jump between these orbits
emitting energy h nu in the form of
light and the interesting thing is he
could calculate these energy levels
and they were not equally spaced like
this harmonic oscillator
that we were just talking about and so
this spacing of the energy levels
depends a little bit
on the nature of the forces involved and
uh the e equals h nu was
was just true for harmonic oscillator
and now we knew how to calculate the
energy levels of atoms
okay and because you have different uh
spacings then that means different
frequencies of light
can be emitted from the atom but they're
discrete frequencies
um but this orbit picture turned out to
be wrong
it took 13 more years to to really come
up with a
more quantitative theory which is
essentially the modern theory
this was done mainly by heisenberg and
uh irwin schroedinger
and they replaced this orbit picture
with the picture of clouds of
probability
there was this idea that a state for an
atom
would be not an orbit and that the the
electron was actually could be in some
sort of cloudy region
uh with a particular kind of uh
variation of the cloud depending on how
much energy it had
and it's related to this thing called a
wave function we'll be talking about a
little bit
and in this case the position of the
electron in the wave function is
uncertain
you'll find it in different places when
you measure for the same state
but uh but if you measure the energy
you'll always get the quantized energy
and on in this talk and for what we're
going to do in quantum information
today i'm going to mostly focus on
variables that are discrete like the
energy here
that can only take quantized values
okay so we're moving right along with
quantum mechanics
so um so one thing that followed from
the theory that was invented
in 25 26 27 was that
when an atom was emitting light through
this quantum jump
that it could actually be in between the
two states
in a state called a superposition which
we write this way
so psi is this wave function and it's
proportional to an equal sum
of the two states and i'm being very
vague mathematically here
but the meaning of this superposition at
least partially was that when you
measured the energy
of the electron in this superposition 50
percent of the time
you would get the uh the the energy
level e2
and 50 of the time you get the energy
level e3
okay and you also can have unequal
superpositions like you could have
something with a half there and that
would correspond to finding e2
75 percent of the time and e3 25
of the time okay um so so far maybe
that's not too upsetting
now to talk about this in an information
theoretic way
we're going to replace the two levels by
a zero and a one as in the states of a
bit which we're going to call a quantum
bit
uh but this is a bit that can be in this
uh
superposition state and while every
quantum system has
usually many energy levels or an
infinite number
in actual using it for information
processing we're often going to focus on
just two levels
or a few and so you know this we we talk
about this quantum bit as if there were
only two levels
until the other levels start to come in
and then we'll we'll
move away from that but mainly we're
going to talk about quantum bits
now uh measuring a quantum bit in
superposition is this just the same
as measuring a coin that's been tossed
inside a box
right so it's let's say you know it's a
50 50 super position
so i toss a coin inside a box i i don't
look at it yet
and then when i open it up i have a 50
chance of getting tails
or i do it again 50 chance of having uh
heads
uh so um and then an unequal
superposition could be just like a
biased coin
you know which is somehow loaded to come
up more like heads and tails
uh and uh you know more heads than tails
so where's the big philosophical problem
with a biased coin i mean that doesn't
sound like a
total showstopper okay well here's where
it starts to get
uh more challenging okay so uh
i do this i don't look at it so there
uh but uh and then same thing i do it
again
i get some value for heads of heads or
tails
uh but when i finally open the box i'm
able to assume that
before i opened the box it had the value
before i actually could see it
quote unquote measure so the inability
to predict heads or tails when i
toss a coin is a matter of ignorance you
know i don't know what it is if i don't
look at it i don't but it was that
before i measured it
so measurement just reveals the state
that was there before
now you can't say this for quantum bits
it really is not true
in insofar as physics can talk about
truth so that's where things start to
get complicated and now i'll try to
explain why
okay so the usual coin would be you know
50 50.
we're going to call it zero in one state
uh
uh but you know if it's biased i could
have a totally loaded coin that's
completely
always comes up head or always comes up
tails
or it could have anything in between say
comes up
two-thirds uh tails and one-thirds head
that's there's nothing surprising and
all the different kinds of probabilistic
behavior are on this line here
uh but qubit states are not like that
okay
with this equal superposition i showed
you is like the 50 50
unbiased coin but i can
write a different quantum state where i
put a minus sign
in front of in front of the state one
and that'll also be 50 50 when i measure
it
and then there are nastier ones that i'm
not showing you that involve complex
numbers
and in fact there's actually an infinity
of unbiased coins
and the states of a quantum bit uh
you know can't be described by a line
they have to be described by this
sphere where always having one the
totally
biased coin is the two poles of the
sphere
okay and the two states i just wrote
here would be
would be states uh would be on the
equator
of the sphere and the equator is a
circle and so there's a continuum of
unbiased states all of which are
distinct
and then you can ask the you know when
you measure the energy
they're still going to be 50 50. okay
after you measure the energy if you get
one
it's going to stay one until something
else
manipulates it so the measurement has
changed the state it's now completely
one
even though it started out in that state
it was 50 50 1 and 0.
okay so what makes these all these
different unbiased states on the equator
of this sphere different states well you
can tell they're different when you
measure something else which is not the
energy
and to keep life simple we're going to
assume you measure something
which is uh discrete and can just be
zero or one
but a different meaning of zero one some
other physical property like momentum or
something else angular momentum
um now these states on the equator
won't be unbiased when you measure this
other property
and the bias will not be the same so
they're not the same state
and uh and and they don't map onto just
a biased or unbiased coin okay so
do we really have to accept that the
state is uncertain until we measure
could we still interpret our
observations as learning what was
already there
which is certainly was from the very
beginning the question
that people uh asked because they wanted
to think of
physics as objective reality independent
of measurement
so the answer is no we can't say we
can't do that
it seems like in quantum mechanics
measurement is affecting the system and
making it choose
properties the properties are not
independent
of the actual measurement and bohr
responded to this by saying get over it
this is
known more formally as the copenhagen
interpretation or complementarity and he
just says your choice of measurement
determines what you can know and there
are questions that
don't have an answer you shouldn't
expect them to have answers
uh later is actually proved that any new
theory which assumes properties of
quantum bits
they're independent of how they're
measured could never agree with all the
predictions of quantum mechanics
and more was i'm fine with that okay
but not einstein so einstein famously in
1935
wrote this paper with two young
colleagues at the institute for advanced
studies
uh called can the quantum mechanical
description of physical
reality be considered complete and
um in it he he did a thought experiment
he liked those
in which uh he tried to argue that it
can't be considered
complete and this the reason that he
argued was related to the con that the
his argument was related to the concept
of entanglement
so entanglement is again i have two
qubits
i don't know what their state is okay
and but i put them a state that has the
property that if i get
there two of them and they're in a joint
state and
when i measure them if i know what one
is i immediately find the other one has
to be the same
so that their their values are called
entangled
now each coin separately is unbiased and
just comes up 50 50
as entails but as soon as i if i measure
the second one
actually it has to be the same these are
these magic
coins also known as epr pairs after
uh einstein oldar analsky and rosen
uh so and they look like this in our
notation so you either get one and one
or zero and zero
and you never get um zero one or one
zero
um so
each coin individually carries no
information because it's not
biased but the correlation does the
entanglement does carry information
because you know something about this in
this state zero one will never happen
and one zero will ever happen
so you have one bit of information but
it's it's shared between the two
bits now the thing that makes it even
worse and that einstein particularly
objected to
is the following suppose i have these
entangled uh
state and i take one of the bits and i
let it fly off a great distance like
a light year or something like that and
then i do the measurement here
and i find heads well since you have to
get
um you have to get heads on the other
bit that's far away
and you know if i measured it first
um you know i it would have been random
so it sort of feels like this
measurement here
affected the measurement over there now
turns out you can prove you can't send
information with these correlations you
can't go faster than life
but still it looks very impossible or
very wrong
and so how can a measurement here affect
the the result there
einstein said it can't sometimes he
would make fun of the whole idea of
measurement
uh affecting reality by saying do you
really think the moon isn't there when
you aren't looking at it
um and he thought there must be a better
theory where
only things near each coin determine
what their value is
and somehow we can still explain the
correlation that exists
so this brilliant young theorist back in
64
john bell actually took up einstein's
challenge said could there be a better
theory
is that even allowed and he figured out
the the following theorem okay
uh so um
so in his theory he calculate the
correlation between
two measurements of qubits i'm not going
to go exact into exactly what kind of
measurement that would be but it's
similar to checking uh
you know which state it's in but it's a
little more complicated
and he calculated how this correlation
would vary with a certain angle that you
vary in the measurement
and you see this blue curve i'm calling
quantum
and uh that's the prediction that
quantum mechanics gives for this
measurement
and the red curve bell established is
the the largest values you can have
from any theory that einstein would like
that only depends on the local variables
and so he said just go out and look at
this and
see if we violate this inequality if we
don't
then quantum mechanics is wrong and the
einstein friendly theory could be there
could be found but if we if we do
violate this inequality
then we could never explain it with the
theory that einstein would accept
and uh so that's the difference between
these at this particular angle
this difference if we see this einstein
is wrong if we see oops if we see the
the the red then uh maybe einstein was
right
and this young french physicist alain
aspay in 82
did a very good experiment to test this
there were some earlier ones but this
certainly was one of the very best first
early ones and there's his curve and you
see it looks like a blue curve
and it violates what are called bell's
inequalities
so that means we'll never be able to get
the kind of theory
that einstein was looking for and we
really have to accept
these weird properties of entanglement
and really
many many experiments have been done and
you know this kind of thing has been
verified in different forms over and
over again
so the consensus is that the world is
really this weird
yes the world is really that way okay
now
bell really was kind of upset by this
and he wrote
einstein was the rational man the
reasonable thing that he thought just
doesn't work
so he was hoping that maybe uh you'd
find a problem with the quantum
prediction but we didn't
okay so to summarize we've learned
quantum mechanics right
sort of quantum systems can live in an
uncertain state called a superposition
two-level system of these then is
considered a qubit
that's a certain kind of superposition
uh which we've talked about
a lot and any quantum system when you
measure it
it it decides what state it's in it
collapses into a state with a certain
value of the thing you measured
the probability of each state is
determined by what the initial
superposition was
so it won't always be the same thing
it's contradictory to assume it always
was in the state you measured
before you measure it that's the
toughest part of it in a certain way
so this physicist aleksey karatkov said
in quantum mechanics you don't see what
you get you get what you see
so um finally qubits can be in this
perfectly correlated state while still
behaving individually
random and this is an example of
entanglement
okay and the state looks like that or in
coins it looks like that
all right so we're good here right we've
mastered quantum mechanics
um we've done it though we've done it
okay test tomorrow come to this link
uh so we've covered most of the hard
stuff
okay and now we're gonna understand
quantum computing quantum
information a little bit so much later
in 1927 there was the fifth salve
conference
and uh einstein was there looking like
the more familiar einstein
there's boar there's heisenberg there's
schrodinger
and then there's this guy whose name was
paul dirac
paul dirac actually right after
heisenberg
kind of put quantum mechanics in an
extremely elegant form and predicted new
things that nobody had
other people hadn't figured out and was
generally considered to be a
genius um and he said in 1929 that
the underlying physical laws necessary
for the mathematical theory of a large
part of physics
and the whole of chemistry are thus
completely known
this is a famous quote the rest of the
quote is often not
given and he says the difficulty is only
that the exact
application of these laws leads to
equations much
too complicated to be soluble therefore
becomes desirable that
practical methods of applying quantum
mechanics should
be developed well for the next 50 years
quantum mechanics turned out to be the
theory of everything
and nobody really wanted to worry about
these foundational issues and
philosophical issues
and there was this acronym suac shut up
and calculate
which was in force when i started my phd
for sure so you weren't supposed to
worry about these things if you were
serious about physics
now but the dirty secret
was we know the equations that would
describe many
complex systems of atoms and molecules
or even subatomic
particles but we often can't solve them
okay and this is due to something that i
call the the exponential wall
now um because of the pandemic people
are familiar
with exponential growth like you infect
one person
and each person there invests you know
uh uh
one more you know one more so two turns
into four into
et cetera et cetera and it grows very
quickly
um so uh so it turns out that the
equations of quantum mechanics are sort
of like that
in the sense that as the system gets
more complicated
uh first with the simple system we can
actually solve it with pencil and paper
and give exams to undergraduates
expecting them to be able to do that
uh and then as it gets more complicated
you have two atoms or three
then we turn to a computer
but if we really try to solve them
exactly for i don't know
any medium-sized molecule and we we do
that using
a ordinary digital computer
there is a brute force way to solve
these equations
they're called partial differential
equations but we find
that as the number of atoms and
molecules increase
the time that it's going to take our
computer to crank out the answer
is um growing and pretty soon we're
estimating that it's going to take the
history of mankind and then the history
of the earth and so on
and so there's no way to directly solve
those that we know
prior to quantum computing in human time
scales
now in many cases we found approximate
methods that avoid the exponential wall
and seem to agree with nature
so we've made a lot of progress but in
the cases where we don't
have a good approximation we can't
predict anything
so that is that is the dirty secret and
this
really describes many of the frontier
problems in theoretical physics
that we're trying to get around the
exponential wall
okay now uh getting back down to quantum
information
okay uh one of the few famous physicists
who
was involved with the quantum
information fringe was richard feynman i
hope many of you have heard of him and
uh in 1981
actually i was there but i didn't know
about this conference there was a
conference on the physics of
uh computing and feynman came and gave
the keynote
address such as it was and he said
um okay now that i'm blocking here
actually the quote but you can see it
can you simulate
uh simulate nature with a new kind of
quantum computer it's not a turing
machine it's a machine of a different
kind
with quantum computer elements meaning
the hardware itself
was in a quantum state of superposition
or something
like that and uh so he says it's not a
turing machine it's not a
what we now would call a classical
computer well nature isn't
classical damn it and if you want a
similar simulation of nature you better
make it quantum
and by golly it's a wonderful problem
because it doesn't look too
easy so that's how feynman talked
and he realized that you know maybe this
would get around the exponential wall
but this seemed like a crazy idea
right because we've already told you
that quantum
bits exist in an uncertain state i
haven't even told you how fragile they
are
but even if you have them if they're in
a superposition you know they
they may randomly fall into one state or
another uh so you can't even
reliably store your bits why would you
want something that's
uh you know could be a zero or a one
um so forget about processing in some
predictable way to solve a problem you
are introducing noise and loss of
information at the basic hardware level
how could that be good but
as these people thought what if quantum
weirdness is a feature and not a bug
and the basic idea of quantum
stimulation is that if the components of
your computer can keep their quantumness
and are hooked up and are programmed so
they have the same kinds of
interactions and forces as the atoms in
a molecule
say that you're trying to uh calculate
the energy levels of
then just by running your computer there
will be a way to extract
the energy level that you can't actually
do with a normal computer
just as this is just a quantum analog
simulator now i must hasten to say
that none of our computers before ever
had quantum components in this sense
okay so if you did this it turns out
there would be no exponential wall
and you would be able to treat much
larger quantum systems
predictably so throughout the 80s
scientists explored the properties of
quantum information
and interesting things were found you
can find a history there
on wikipedia but really the big
the big moment was
in 1994. so 1994 peter shore
who was an applied mathematician and
computer scientist
at bell labs at the time
he proved
he was looking at this and quantum
calculations aren't the only exponential
walls
so as an applied mathematician and
computer science he was interested in
other exponential walls
and he had heard about this idea of a
potential quantum computer
and he showed that a quantum computer
could solve a computer science math
problem
with an exponential wall which was
believed to have an exponential wall
so in other words it wasn't just a way
to simulate quantum mechanics and do
physical science calculations
it was also a way to solve problems
in applied math that could apply to
finance to cryptography etc
where exponential walls are everywhere
in networking and communications and so
on
here's an example of a non-physics
exponential
wall that probably you can relate to
this is somebody's estimate
of the days of computer time it would
take to crack a password of different
length in terms of letters so your
desktop can do up to five letters and
then it's going to start taking
much longer than you're willing to wait
uh a graphical
processing unit which is very fast for
gaming
it can go up to six and then an amazon
cloud cluster
can go up to seven or eight and it's
very clear that if you have
20 letters in your password you're never
going to get there
so this is nothing to do with physics
this is these are problems in
information science
or in cryptography rather that we want
to know the answers to
okay so sure showed that if you had an
ideal quantum computer
with perfect qubits and other things
perfect
uh you could break the standard
encryption technology
which underlies web browsing and
e-commerce on the internet
so this was a moment
this was a moment that shocked the world
uh
okay so what am i talking about um
so cryptographers like exponential walls
particularly if they're one-way walls
that is that one way it's very hard to
find the answer but the other way when
you decrypt it's easy
and factoring large numbers into their
primes is a convenient
one-way wall mathematicians and computer
scientists knew this
and it's used in something called rsa
encryption
which is used to send your credit card
on the internet
uh just to remind you what a prime
number is and a little bit about them
uh so you know 20 is 1 times 2 times 2
times 5
a prime well okay 21 is as shown there
22 is as shown there
um uh and uh a prime number is
i didn't show itself as a factor i
should have uh
a prime a prime number has no factors
but one and itself and i'm
sure most of you do remember that i hope
now you might think well
you know we kind of just look at this
and we figure this out it's true
we could do that for not too big numbers
uh but if they're really big numbers
then it's not easy to do
so trying factoring this guy
so this is not a randomly chosen number
that i typed
this is rsa 2048 um
it's a 617 decimal digit
200 2048 bits uh
integer which is semi-prime i'll explain
that what it
so it's not a prime number and um it's
uh
it's one of the largest longest numbers
that they use in this encryption scheme
that i'm going to tell you about
and they offered many years ago two
hundred thousand dollars
to uh factorize this number uh
and as wikipedia says it may not be
factorizable for many years to come
so rsa 2048 has only two prime factors
other than one in itself
so p times q multiplied together
gives us this long number but it's very
hard to figure out p and q
okay and actually still no person or
computer system on earth can find that
this
the factors p and q of this number
except
the people that constructed it who
hopefully aren't revealing it
so you know you could offer somebody
billions of dollars there is this is an
unsolvable problem
we believe at the moment with the the
finest
uh techniques we know um
so the you know the team at rsa found p
and q by
to find large primes and then they
multiplied them together and there is a
way to find large primes
so multiplying is easy right that you
could even probably do although it could
probably make a mistake with this long
number
but a computer can do that easily but
figuring out the prime factors is
believed to be exponentially hard and
have an exponential wall
so there's a one way wall it's easy to
compute n
knowing p and q it's quote unquote
impossible to compute p and q
knowing n okay unless you have a quantum
computer post sure
okay now the way this is often
illustrated is
uh we're going to send a message that we
want to encrypt between
bob and alice and each of those know the
factors of n
i'm not even sure they both have to but
i just assuming that
okay this is my bob's credit card number
so he sends it by encoding it
in a message of bits that depend on n
okay and he sends that message over and
then
knowing uh the factors of end alice can
decode it
and get uh bob's credit card number and
if eve
is listening she's an eavesdropper or
you know uh has has corrupted the the
security of the line
she will get an end but she won't be
able to find the prime factors and she
won't be able to decode it
and this is literally one of the main
ways that the internet allows you to
send your credit card
secured currently so
when shore happened kryptarger first
raced for a quantum
revolution and by 2015 the us
nsa had revealed its intention to
transition to quantum resistant
protocols meaning that we won't use
rsa we'll find some other method that so
far we haven't figured out if a quantum
computer could break
okay but we're still using it regularly
and we don't
have a quantum computer unless something
very surprising is out there
that could could break rsa at the moment
okay um so once the shore algorithm was
invented the race was on
i mean you know intelligence privacy
e-commerce finance i mean all these
things care about
uh being able to crypt and encrypt and
decrypt
and so on and suddenly there was this
paradigm shift
quantum uncertainty wasn't always a
barrier to learning about nature
actually it could be the key to
extracting previously inaccessible
knowledge
and you had to invent new hardware which
would qualitatively change
uh the the the type of the problem so
before we thought
uh that pro if a problem was
exponentially hard on one type of
computer it would be exponentially hard
on any kind of computer
but according to shore's result that's
not true if you have the
new revolutionary quantum hardware this
exponentially hard problem
could become solvable
okay now it turns out that all quantum
speed up
derives from superstition and
entanglement
so if nature wasn't like this we could
never solve these problems it would
forever be
outside of reach um and it uses
everything einstein hated about
quantum mechanics so there's quite a
historical pioneer irony
there and it's a new kind of machine
never previously attempted in science
and technology
so let me try to explain how it could be
in some sense
so much more powerful although this is a
very simplified illustration
so uh this is a conventional computer
uh ram chip with a hundred billion bits
on it um but and each
bid has two states so there are two to
the end states
uh that uh that this this chip could
hold
two to the hundred billion is an
insanely large number
in fact 300 2 to the 300
is actually an insanely large number uh
it's
10 to the 91 states
so if we were to explore all states
sequentially
at one nanosecond so we just turned on
this chip
and started you know with all zeros and
then flipped one and then another and
just did this
once a nanosecond okay it would take
greater than the age of the universe
sorry
uh it would take longer the age of the
universe to just do this
um in uh you know in a serial
classical way but in a quantum computer
it would take
uh less than a second so we start with
all zeros in the quantum version
and we don't flip one we actually
superpose it
we turn it into an equals equal
superposition of zero and one
which is something we know how to do
okay
and then we do that for the next one and
the next one and eventually when we've
done that 300 times
we actually have all 10 to the 91 terms
in this big sum all of which are
now being partially implemented in this
300 bit quantum register so in that
sense it does something completely
impossible
classically and but
very doable quantum mechanically
and this would take less than a nano
than a millisecond actually on a quantum
computer we think we don't have one yet
but
so the quantum computer is the ultimate
parallel processor
uh but it may also be the most difficult
technology we've ever tried to
build so why why is a quantum computer
insanely difficult to build
okay classical bit is high or low
voltage in a small circuit
and the bit can just stay there
uncorrupted for years
or a magnetic region and a magnetic disc
or whatever
the quantum bit is a real or artificial
atom with quantum levels
okay so there's a real atom and there's
an artificial atom this is one of the
ones pioneered in yale where i have a
superconducting structure
that has energy levels and can be uh
treated as a kind of artificial
atom okay but the unprotected qubit if i
just leave it out
in the environment it's going to just go
away in a nanosecond
okay it just uh it just uh can't stay in
some superposition
and the reason it can't is because being
out in the world is in an environment
where atoms are bumping into you where
light is coming in radiation is coming
in
and it's measuring the qubit and it's
making it decide
what state it's in even though humans
don't measure it the environment is
measuring it
so that's why calm information is
incredibly fragile
this effect is called decoherence and
that's why we couldn't have a real
shooting or a cat
because anything big and living like a
cat is interacting with the environment
to stay alive
and so it's not going to be in a
superposition okay
but um so quantum information is like
the most fragile kind of information
ever
ever invented okay well that sounds hard
but can't we just shield our qubits from
the environment and keep them far apart
from each
other i mean we knew how to trap
individual atoms
20 30 years ago you know we can cool
things down
can't we just do that well that's not
enough
okay because you need to interact your
qubits
to process that's how you for example
you need to create entanglement
so here's my qubit one that's in state
one
let's say i want to put it into a
superposition so i i
zap it with some microwaves or laser and
i put it into zero one in a controllable
way
now i have to bring my next qubit in
that's also in that superposition
now i want to entangle it so i want to
get rid of the one zero zero one state
so they have to talk to each other
and eventually i'll end up with the
entangled state so i had these
interactions that have to go perfectly
any mistake i'm not going to get the
right state
so this is so difficult that we think we
will need error correction and hardware
which we do have in
on computers you know we store a one as
three ones
and then take the majority and so on uh
but it's much harder to do what possible
to do in quantum mechanics
um now the current quantum computers
they're basically
two main technologies the one that was
pioneered
here at yale and other places involves
the superconducting circuits
that you cool down to a hundredth of a
degree above absolute zero
and then these artificial atoms are on
chips
they're little superconducting regions
uh that are
particularly uh uh specially designed
this approach was pioneered by my
colleagues michel deverey steve girvin
and
rob shulkoffs i want to shout out to
them and this is called a transmon qubit
which pretty much all the
industrial places are using now
now the other approach is to use real
atoms and this
blue thing here is a string of trapped
ions
it's ionized atoms which can be
manipulated with laser beams and has to
be
kept in an ultra high vacuum so um
so uh that's also extremely fragile but
okay
so we immediately see that quantum
computers are not going to be small
they're not going to be portable and
they're not going to be cheap but they
are going to you know they they because
they have unique capability you can
imagine that a quantum cloud
would still be very very powerful and
uh desirable now uh you might worry that
while it's pretty easy to think that a
single ion
suspended in space is sort of uh not
near its
neighbors you know stuff on a chip where
we have solids made of other atoms
you might say it's probably quite
difficult to make that
want that type of qubit
avoid decoherence and it was quite
difficult
back in the 90s when they were first
proposed and demonstrated
uh you had about a nanosecond before
they became useless
and then uh over uh the last uh
what is it sort of 20-ish years there's
been a six
order of magnitude improvement so that
we can store
quantum information on a chip and
uh most of this improvement was done by
people at yale
also the world leader in quantum era
correction which i don't have time to go
into
so in the last three minutes here let me
say something about
what quantum computing could do for
mankind
so this is a picture of einstein again
got to get him in there
with his friend fritz harper and
uh haber invented something called the
haber bosch process
in the beginning of the 20th century and
it's a way
to extract nitrogen from the air and
make ammonia ammonia
is a very critical component of
fertilizer
and this led to the green revolution of
the second half of the 20th century
and it's actually a very tough bond to
break this nitrogen bond so it's very
energy intensive and it has to be done
at
250 bars of pressure which is
the pressure two and a half kilometers
under the sea
and at 450 degrees centigrade which is
the
melting point of aluminum so uh it's
very energy intensive
and uh it emits a lot of co2 when you do
this
in fact the
national academy of sciences estimated
that
uh one percent of total u.s energy
for uh gas um
uh oil it was let's say a net energy of
natural gas
is used yearly just for the harbor bosch
process so one percent
of all the energy we use goes into this
and creates a lot of co2
so a grand challenge in quantum
chemistry would be
to figure out how we could do this much
less energy intensively
and then here's this uh this cofactor
called famoco
which if you uh let bacteria have it
uh they can produce nitrogen from
soil at room temperature and pressure
instead of at the
pressure of the bottom of the sea and so
on um
and we don't know how they do it it's
too complicated we don't know enough
about the properties of this cofactor to
figure out
if we did maybe we could
we could actually turn it into
industrial process and save an enormous
amount
of energy another example i like
is something related to biomedical
science in this case
these guys zells and demler they talked
to medical biophysicists to ask
what could a quantum computer do for you
since devler seems to be
married to a biophysicist this was
probably relatively easy
and they talked about this metabolic
dark matter
so we all know about genomics and some
people know about
uh catego cataloging all the pro
the proteins proteomics but then the
next level of functional things
in the body are called metabolites and
they're 200 000 metabolites
and we only know what one percent of
them do and so on
and so um we'd like to know that but the
way we try to figure it out
was by shining nmr radiation on them and
looking at the signal we get back and
this is very sparse information
and from this signal it's very hard to
figure out a complicated structure
okay and uh so this is how we're doing
it now
but we can't do it that well um and uh
cells and his co-workers designed an
algorithm
which uses a combination of pattern
recognition
and ai and quantum simulation to
identify metabolites from spectra
and it used the shore like speed up the
same thing that shore used
to speed up factorization and
they did some examples and they were
able to
to reproduce known spectra you might say
well how did they do that because they
don't have a quantum computer
and the answer is they they only did it
up to the exponential wall
and they're just hoping if we get a
quantum computer they can go through the
exponential wall
but they're checking that the idea is
working with a classical computer
simulating a quantum computer okay
so uh that's uh that's all i wanted to
uh all i wanted to get across
about how exciting and uh
interesting the next phase is and how
philosophically
and conceptually important the calm
information revolution
is uh so so we're going boldly into the
quantum future
and uh we'll we'll we yale hope to be
finding out what happens there thank you
for your
yeah there's a lot of attention clipping
happening uh thank you so much for
uh for this talk um doug um we have a
question from annie you talked a little
bit about what quantum computer could do
um can you tell us uh for
the question is what kind of complex
problem quantum computer have
solved so far um okay
i mean maybe didn't make this clear so
there aren't
quantum computers really i mean they're
very very kind of rudimentary
and people are using that but
uh you know at the moment we
we have you know dozens of qubits
not even a hundred that work together
they don't work together
flexibly and so on so there is no
quantum computer that's really doing
stuff
yet that's groundbreaking stuff there
are lots of little examples of things
they're doing
the first thing people are doing is to
try to not the first thing but one of
the first things
is to look at actual molecules um
because that's kind of a very natural
thing for quantum stimulation
and we have bigger quantum simulators
from multi-purpose computers
so that's kind of things going on but so
far
just looks really promising nothing's
been
shown yet and i guess the question that
i have and a multiple question on that
is uh it doesn't exist yet but like when
do you think it will happen
uh well i think that's the million
dollar question
so um my colleague rob shulkoff
i hope i'm quoting correctly i think you
know
to have something that you really can
learn how to use the quantum computer
and start doing things which i'd say
we're not even quite there yet
that's going to be only five years maybe
maybe less
um the the breakthrough
the change in human society
the economy i don't know i don't think
it's either going to fail massively or
it's going to be here in 20 years
but that's just my gut feeling you know
there's been unbelievable progress
made so that's my gut feeling but this
is all over the map
and a lot of people you know are saying
it's already here we're already doing it
you can buy our web services you know so
you're going to hear off a big spectrum
of answers to that question
um are there any problem where even
quantum computer can hit the
exponential wall you were talking about
earlier um
well a partial answer to this well first
yes in the sense that we don't know the
full capabilities of a quantum computer
and so there are lots of problems that
exponential walls we haven't figured out
a quantum algorithm
to solve them fast and i don't know
whether there's any proofs that there
don't exist ones
but specifically the new kinds of coding
problems
the coding they want to do they're going
to use another math problem not
factoring
prime numbers i'm sorry finding prime
factors of large numbers
uh they're going to use a different kind
of hard math problem where
nobody's come up with a quantum
algorithm and i think some people are
much
further along than me and understanding
which ones can
and cannot uh be solved but certainly
there are many
exponentially hard problems we haven't
figured on an algorithm
another thing i want to mention is that
and this is now i'm quoting a very
knowledgeable person from microsoft
matthias troyer
who said that you know quantum computing
is going to be good for hard compute
problems not for big data problems
so if there's some place in the
program or in the in the calculation
where there's an exponential wall
you'll use a quantum computer if you
want to have massive storage
and so on and be able to use it uh
actually you you're gonna use a
classical computer that's gonna be
easier in certain ways
so that's that was his general take on
it
so networking and the kinds of things
that google want to do is very much a
hard compute problem i'm glad you're
talking about google that's the perfect
segue to the next question
um somebody is asking um what did google
do with the quantum computing like
the quantum computer i felt last year
and the quantum supremacy
so
you know let's find a problem which
um a problem which has an exponential
wall
um that may be the easiest problem for
to make quantum hardware for and let's
show that we can get an answer when no
uh no classical uh
computer could so it's not it is not a
useful problem
and there's big arguments about whether
it's even an interesting problem
i heard both sides argued recently here
in the quantum institute
uh you know uh but uh but uh
it wasn't a practical problem so they
did
um so they did a uh
a kind of sorting problem that's not
even right
but uh it's essentially a statistical
problem
where you had to detect a certain
statistical behavior
that was characteristic of interference
in quantum mechanics
and you could try to simulate that
problem on a classical computer
and they got to a size where no
classical computer could do it
and they got an answer which looked to
be
measuring quantum interference it was
not
dramatic it was the quantum mechanics
predicted two
and they got 1.06 uh
and so their computer was not working
perfectly
but they claimed that the classical
computer couldn't have even gotten the
0.06
so it was a very abstruse uh abstract
problem
that uh you know they wanted to claim
quantum supremacy
so but i think the fact that they got so
close
is showing that we're making progress
and they're different
um approaches our approach here at yale
has been
to try to do quantum error correction
and do
much cleaner quantum computations with
smaller numbers of bits and so on
and so that's the approach we've chosen
other uh google's chosen one approach
uh ibm is more or less going more
in our direction and so on um
so yes it was a big deal because it did
show something
beyond what a classical computer uh
could do
um so in that sense it's big but it's a
tiny
tiny inch above the threshold i mean
it's not anything dramatic yet
um um somebody asked the question
um i've noticed there's a lot of
physicists
working on these topics with the
background of in physics what are the
possibility for engineers in this field
so my understanding uh from talking to
rob shulkoff the director of this
institute who
founded the qci the this startup company
it's um oh sorry what do i need to do
yeah okay sorry um
is uh that actually more than half the
people or half the people are engineers
and software engineers
and so on uh so i think it's very clear
that this is a field where we'll need
lots of
electrical engineers computer scientists
uh
software engineers uh probably
mechanical engineers
anyway so uh there's a lot of
opportunity there but
the big barrier the exponential wall
here is that you have to understand
something about quantum mechanics
and so we're working on educational you
know courses that can take someone
without a full physics background and
get you know they could just use my talk
but
it's probably not quite deep enough to
to to do that so yes there will be a big
role for engineers
and then we can also say that the yellow
quantum institute regroups departments
atl in physics applied physics computer
science electrical engineering
uh chemistry so there's really trying to
bring um everybody
it's naturally interdisciplinary
and also at least for the moment it's
like a
a seller's seller's market so
anybody with quantum training that's
legit you can get hired
maybe without you know doing any postdoc
or maybe out of your phd but we don't
like that so
forget i said that um anyway
thank you there's a lot more question uh
pouring in
um what in particular do you see
the yqri team contributing to the commit
decades like what what's next
what do you think that's the year labs
will uh will bring
in the field thank you i don't know
it's an anonymous thing maybe somebody
from really sending us that like a
global question for us
so i didn't want to be too parochial but
i think that i mean yale deserves a lot
of credit both for inventing a lot of
the
foundational stuff but for taking a
completely different and very patient
uh systematic approach and is in
in doing that they've actually changed
the paradigm and only a few people
only a few other places as of last year
no one with yale was doing this i
understand now
some other people are doing this and
they stopped
me they would started stop using the
superconducting circuits
as their artificial atoms they started
actually using
photons light in cavities and i i
don't have a picture here but uh
it doesn't look like the flat thing that
i have here
uh right the new thing looks like
something you might have on your cable
box
yeah it doesn't look like that flat
thing that i
that i i have in this picture it's much
more like a
it's three-dimensional and it um it's
small it's not as big as your cable box
but you know it's uh it looks very
different
and uh and that's because we're storing
the information in light
and the reason we're storing information
in light or in photons actually
microwave photons
um is because photons don't interact
strongly
and uh they have fewer ways that they
can actually disappear
and so we've already shown that they can
have 10 times
longer uh lifetimes than the
superconducting qubits we used to use
so and we we hope to pioneer this method
of using storage with photons
and processing with superconducting
elements
which is new you know it's unique to
yale and now now
spreading a little bit and then the
second thing is
that we hope to add error correction
efficient error correction
way before anybody else and i won't
i won't tell you you know it gets pretty
technical why we think
we are so far ahead but uh we have good
reasons
to think this that answer a lot of
question uh in the
the q a regarding like the the
investment of china on quantum
computings they are they are
wondering what are the uh the
implications of of this and if they will
have gone on with it before but i think
you've answered this question saying
like
we we hope that the uh the yield team
has something
uh well also i think that
um the the idea of encryption
and you know and sending encrypted
measurement
messages is very exciting to the chinese
and lots of people
to be fair and they've been really
pushing quantum communication
not quantum computing i guess they're
catching up somewhat
quantum computing and um so
and one of the things i didn't get to
say is that
there is a proof that you can send
unbreakable
coded messages with quantum mechanics
and
that is out there already and it's being
sold commercially
we don't know who's using it in defense
uh so i think they're very much
interested in the
secrecy coding decoding aspect of it
more than the quantum computing at the
moment but that's just a guess
um and i think the the clock is running
and i'm gonna maybe
uh end on this question uh since we're a
university we have a question from a
college student
and they um willis is asking like what
could um a student do today to prepare
for quantum computing in the future what
are the
subjects or major you should consider is
it better to do cs or physics like what
is the
um what is your take on uh on a young
person who wants to to join the efforts
uh i think that
both are very good so you should do what
you like more
specifically shore who was not trained
in quantum mechanics but just kind of
understood the math of quantum mechanics
was able to find this thing
you know that he knew stuff in computer
science and in complexity theory
that most physicists at that time didn't
know and and he made the revolution
honestly so i started the revolution
so in that sense you know you can master
the math
uh and do something as a computer
scientist or applied mathematician
um uh you know being a physicist
if you want to work on hardware that's
definitely a good idea to be a physicist
or if there are joint efforts between
physics and engineering
you could be an engineer you know so
that would be an answer i think either
are promising
and there's also the the question he had
was like um
he was worried about having uh his work
on computer science being obsolete by
the time
the since the field is moving so fast um
and so that's that's the that was also
one of the
concern and i think in that case people
have here are working really in
collaboration we also
we talked a lot with the people in
computer science here and so i think the
the fields is moving along and um so
yeah i
also i sort of said this but i said it
fast and maybe it's a good thing to end
on
you're not going to have a quantum
computer in your phone you're not going
to have a quantum computer in your house
you don't need a quantum computer in
your house you're not always running up
against
big compute problems with exponential
walls
google is running up against them when
they're trying to route signals and
do you know do stuff over you know a
billion links and so on
uh so you know it's not a replacement
for all of the classical computing and
software or anything like that
so clearly you're not going to be
totally obsolete
unless you're very interested in
complexity theory and even then you
won't be up
obsolete i suspect i think we're going
to end on that note thank you so much um
for tuning in um we have a lot of
unanswered questions they were actually
very technical so maybe in the future
we'll have another event like this for
a slightly more technical approach with
the q a system and maybe
a moderate conversation um thank you so
much for tuning in
we can bring in people that know more
than me
so um you should consider subscribing to
a public event newsletter that you can
find on our website uh quantum
institute.tl.edu forward slash
subscribe um thank you all uh so much
and thank you
doug for taking the time to tell us all
about quantum computers
have a great night
you